[MUSIC]
We still have institutions
that are too big to fail.
And don't let anybody tell you otherwise,
because all the stuff they say
about how they can now fail without
causing collateral harm is not true.
These are institutions that are bigger
than any institution by its size.
Not Apple, not Facebook, not anybody
is as big as say JP Morgan Chase.
They're all connected
together in a big knot,
they're all together of a house of
cards that all works while it works,
and when the next time something really
starts rattling it, is going to be scary.
[MUSIC]
Misconduct pays to the people across
the board, lower level, higher level.
And as a society, we kind of become
a little bit helpless to prevent it,
all we can do is we can't send
a corporation to jail and
then we have not enough means to show
criminality of individuals because it's
all very diffused and very deniable and
difficult to prove in court or whatever.
Or we don't spend the resources
on these kinds of white collar
prosecutions in a corporate context, who
knows all the combination of reasons but.
Bottom line is the consequences for
individuals are usually minimal even when
a lot of wrongdoing is done
in a corporate context.
[MUSIC]
You have people who are angry
with a rigged system, and yet
they don't completely understand the ways
in which the system is really rigged.
And then they are prone to be in directed
to be angry at the wrong targets,
at the media, at immigrants,
at certain countries.
And without actually looking
at some of the issues
that are really corroding and,
distorting, and
corrupting, the democracy
that we have here.
[MUSIC]
I like to give examples
of safety of buildings or
airplanes or bridges or whatever.
Here, the public demand safety
doesn't need to know the details
of the engineering to kind of
demand that that there is a system
that creates safe buildings,
safe bridges, safe flights.
And they will be immediate consequences
for everybody involved and
we wouldn't even know who's responsible,
when that doesn't work.
In the financial system it's
virtually the opposite,
the recklessness is just spread out and
there's no direct line between what
somebody does and
a little bit of excessive rest.
Did they take or
the extra long they make or not make.
And sort of the outcomes and
it's very easy for
the public to get completely
confused about what's going on.
What the public needs is
to see the problem first,
because recognizing the problem
is the first step to solving it.
[MUSIC]